guten abend professor osten genannt der
klever kann südafrika und beruhigen ja
in gewisser weise kann uns das beruhigen
südafrika ist sicherlich ein blick in
eine zukunft in eine endemische
situation die sich dort jetzt gerade
einstellt nur sind wir leider noch ein
ganzes stück davon entfernt
was unterscheidet uns von südafrika na
da muss man vielleicht auch einbeziehen
was gerade in england und in dänemark
beispielsweise passiert wo man eben
sieht was dieses virus macht in einer
winter welle das ist schon mal ein
großer unterschied was dieses virus
macht in bevölkerungen die in erster
linie geimpft sind und nicht schon
mehrmals wahrscheinlich durch infiziert
sondern eben wo die impf immunität jetzt
aufgebaut wird und da
haben wir im moment so ein bisschen
widersprüchliche informationen
einerseits sehen wir diesen sehr starken
anstieg der fälle das ist sehr
besorgniserregend andererseits kriegen
wir gerade aus london beispielsweise und
auch sonst aus england die information
dass eben die falsch wäre vielleicht
doch nicht so ist wie bei den viren mal
schwerer heißt also die erkrankung
richtig die die schwere der erkrankung
im moment gemessen an der zahl
derjenigen die bei infektion ins
krankenhaus müssen diese zahl scheint
geringer zu sein und es ist ja offenbar
so dass dieses virus in diesem moment
alle die menschen erreicht vor allen
dingen die noch nicht geimpft sind und
in deutschland sind unerfreulich viele
menschen verglichen beispielsweise mit
england oder den markt noch nicht
geimpft ja das ist leider ein deutsches
spezial problemen also wenn wir uns die
großen industrieländer in europa
anschauen da hat deutschland tatsächlich
die höchste quote von personen die
keinen kontakt mit dem virus hatten und
auch nicht geimpft sind und wir wissen
nicht was das für uns dann bedeutet also
selbst wenn bei geimpften wie sich das
abzeichnet die krankheit schwerer doch
erträglich werden sollte haben wir eben
diese große gruppe in der bevölkerung um
die man sich da sorgen machen muss und
die sicherlich auch ein bisschen das
politische handeln dann mit bestimmen
wird nun haben sie in den letzten wochen
gesagt dieses omikron virus oder die
variante nikon dieses virus die könnte
sich als ideales virus herausstellen für
den übergang von einer pandemie zu einer
endemischen situation was heißt das auf
deutsch
endemische situation heißt dieses virus
wird zu einem erkältungsvirus wie viele
andere auch wie übrigens vier weitere
corona wären in der vergangenheit schon
und es ist natürlich eine gute situation
über ein virus hat das nicht mehr so
krank macht das aber gut übertragbar ist
so dass es im prinzip alle immunität in
der bevölkerung sucht und findet und
dort immer noch mal so ein update der
immunität hervorruft und
das wird sich dann verlagern zu den
kindern denn diesen die werden ja immer
nach geboren und sind immunologische
naiv während die erwachsenen alle
kontakt mit diesem virus hatten und
häufig daneben mit hilfe der impfung
auch diesen kontakt haben konnten ohne
dabei schwer krank zu werden das heißt
also es könnte eine situation jetzt
kommen im nächsten jahr auf die wir so
gehofft hatten in diesem jahr wir hatten
ja letztes jahr um diese zeit gemeinsam
die erwartung dass nach dem beginn der
impfungen die situation sich
normalisieren würde und niemand ich weiß
die expertin bahn immer skeptisch aber
niemand in der bevölkerung oder wir
journalisten wir haben alle nicht
glauben wollen dass wir ein jahr später
in einer ganz ähnlichen situation sind
können sie den weg zeigen der uns jetzt
in den nächsten drei vier monaten in der
situation bringt dass wir unser normales
leben zurückbekommen na ja also ich
denke es wird in europa und auch in
deutschland so sein dass wir jetzt
vielleicht bis ostern diese situation
jeweils speziell politisch moderieren
müssen also jedes land muss schauen
welche spezial probleme ist hat wie die
infektionen verlaufen hier in
deutschland haben wir gerade schon
gesagt haben wir eben dieses besondere
problem der vielen ungeimpften da muss
eine lösung natürlich her und wir müssen
da sicherlich über die booster kampagne
auch gegen halten dann wird die
temperatur wärmer werden wir kommen ins
zweite quartal dann wird es auch ein
update der impfstoffe geben und ich
denke dass jeder erwachsene sich noch
mal ein update verschaffen sollte also
noch eine weitere impfung
und dann gehen wir in den sommer und
wieder in den winter und im winter wird
sich letztendlich wirklich zeigen wenn
das virus bis dahin sich nicht sehr
stark weiter verändert werden wir
wahrscheinlich einen relativ normalen
winter haben vielleicht wie in einem
normalen schweren influenza winter wo
wir natürlich die alten und gefährdeten
nochmal boostern müssen damit die gut
über die zeit kommen während vielleicht
die normalen gesunden erwachsenen gar
keine booster impfung mehr brauchen das
ist durchaus im bereich des möglichen
und wir dann uns einigermaßen bewegen
können vielleicht muss man noch maske
tragen in bestimmten größeren
situationen innenräumen das will ich
jetzt nicht ausschließen aber unsere
größte sorge im moment muss sein was
passiert mit den ungeimpften in der
bevölkerung gerade mit den älteren
ungeimpften wie bekommen wir das
zumindest bis zum nächsten winter hin
dass die alle geschützt sind das klingt
wie etwas was zu schaffen sein sollte
dankeschön professor thorsten und ein
gutes neues jahr ihnen auch